maybe someday no time soon
it's very impressive what they've done
over the last quarter century but
remember China is still primarily a poor
country with four to five hundred
million poor rural based population a
string of very successful
entrepreneurial operations along the
coastline in a any economic indice
except a gross one gross GNP they will
25 years from now still be quite far
behind us militarily there of course
strengthening as you do as you get more
prosperous but they're way way behind
the military capabilities of the United
States in technology they've become
extremely good at the application of
technology but there's still way behind
in innovation itself so put things in
perspective China is a formidable
country now and it's going to be more so
but it is not a rival of us in power
across the whole spectrum political
power economic nama Crower cultural
power now having said that it is going
to be the number two country in all of
these kinds of things coming up and what
is beginning to happen particularly
since the financial debacle if you will
over the last two years brought on by
the United States and has weakened us at
least for a period of time here as an
economic force and as a model for other
people
China has suddenly moved up the calendar
it had in its head of when it would have
to get really involved in global
governing issues because they saw a
vacuum they saw an opportunity so
they're doing a they have a more
aggressive campaign now for
international investment for building a
blue water Navy to protect their sea
lanes all the way from the Indian Ocean
for straightening out their borders by
telling neighbors that this piece of
land really belongs to China and so on
friction is building up between the
United States and China and Beach
in China and some other countries but it
is not the kind that brought on World
War one or World War two they are not an
expansionist nation they're not an
ideological nation they are a great
power on the making and power never is
transferred or or shared easily in the
international system you've got to grab
for it and they're beginning to do more
of that now that is a problem for us but
there are so many opportunities in
engaging with China and we have to be
careful to keep our sense of balance
about what is really a great national
security threat and what really is the
kind of friction that comes up in this
an artistic thing we call the
international system and I think it's
more the latter than it is the former I
don't think China has any ideas or any
ambitions to end up in a first-class
confrontation with the United States
they're interested in developing China
and that's going to be another 25 to 30
years of heavily focused efforts on
their own economy and their own big
problems of demography of environmental
protection of worker rights of a
political system which in some ways is
very impressive and in other ways is
just antique compared to the kind of
economy they're becoming the idea that
China is going to literally just keep
going at a 10% growth rate and whatever
problem comes up they will deal with
it's just not realistic so they have
some dips in the road coming just like
we all do over historical span and for
us the real challenge is to try and
incorporate them gradually although the
faster pace than was the case before
whatever session incorporate them into
the international system so that they
it's a win-win situation that they win
by being a part of the kind of global
system that we have set up and then I
think you can avoid the most cataclysmic
kind of scenarios that you can here the
problem there though is that the
international system is essentially a
Western creation
and all the major bodies whether we're
talking about the g20 the g8 the IMF the
World Bank have rules and norms of
behavior that we've set and they're
pretty good they're mostly transparent
they're mostly democratic but these
rising powers in which China is the
biggest but Brazil is in that another
Turkey's another and you've seen what
they did recently as far as Imran was
concerned they want to be not just the
beneficiaries of the international
system they quite rightly as they rise
in influence and power they want to be
among those who are the rule setters on
how is the system to behave what kind of
a voice are they going to have in it
that is a very big challenge for us
because so far we have done very little
to transform the international system
and its institutions since just after
World War two the most obvious example
of being the Security Council of the UN
where the great powers of today are only
partially represented and some of them
are left out totally like Japan like
Germany so if you want the biggest
long-term challenge to the United States
I think it is in redoing redoing the
international system so it is more
representative of the world we are in
and are going to become than anything
else
there are lots of tensions building up
in China at the moment they do not
represent a national movement with
linkages between say the the the workers
in Manchuria were upset about not being
paid except once a year or those out in
some of the non haunt and ethnic places
like Tibet and Xinjiang where they are
upset over pollution and and worker
rules that are almost in humans $27
hours a day eight days a week kind of
thing those are at this stage not
unmanageable but they are very big
problems that China has to deal with and
they're doing they're making some
efforts they have a big demographic
problem too because of the one-child
policy which has been in place now for
well over a quarter of a century they
have stopped growing in population and
actually they're going to go off of a
cliff here very soon they're going to go
from having been a young nation to being
a very old one and without a sufficient
safety net for a very large elderly
population they're also going to have
not enough workers for the workforce so
that's a problem they have to deal with
then there is pollution there is no
place on this globe where they are
polluting to the extent that they are in
China you don't see that much of it if
all you are is in Shanghai or Hong Kong
or even Beijing but if you go into the
interior where the new man you just feel
sense cities are being set up it is
awesome and they're running out of water
their deserts are growing in other words
I could go on they have a series of big
systemic problems to deal with and
there's no sign at the moment that they
can't deal with them but there's going
to be a point in time because they are
developing a middle class and a big one
and middle classes when they don't get
the full range of powers that they're
looking for individual freedom work
opportunities and so forth is the most
revolutionary of all classes
and China is facing a period of time
coming up where the middle class which
at the moment thinks it's benefiting
from the one-party political system no
longer thinks that it is and then can
they make the transition evolutionary
rather than in a revolutionary way to a
more pluralistic politics that's a huge
challenge it's not quite there yet but
it's coming right now because they have
been a very efficient set of engineers
at the top of their government the
middle class of China is more Pro
one-party rule than they and they're not
that dissatisfied but I would bet a
bottom dollar that they're going to be
at some point